do you know
there are 1.5 to 5 million fungal
species on the planet earth
and out of those more than 85 species
live on our skin
like many microbes there are helpful
fungi and harmful fungi
when harmful fungi invade the body they
can be difficult to kill
as they can survive in the environment
and re-infect the person trying to get
better
there are several types of fungal
infections that can affect your skin
and many people suffer from fungal
infections at least once in their life
a recent population based survey
reported that these infections are
rarely managed properly
and the prevalence of fungal skin
infections is expected to reach
20 to 25 percent of the world's
population in coming decades
although there are number of fungi that
can cause superficial skin fungal
infections
like candida malassezia etc but the most
common of them belong to a group known
as dermatophytes
dermatophytes are mainly composed of
three species of fungi
the trichophyton epidermophyten and
microsporum
and together they can cause more than 60
to 80 percent of superficial skin
infections in humans
the infection that these dermatophytes
cause is known as dermatophytosis
also known as tinia tinea is derived
from the latin
which stands for worm because formerly
it was considered to be an infection
caused by a worm-like parasite
hence it is still more commonly known as
ringworm
ring-shaped red rash is seen that's
where it gets its name
the ringworm so in this video we will
talk about some of these superficial
fungal skin infections
caused by dermatophytes various measures
that you can do to prevent them in the
first place
and then we will discuss how to treat
them and prevent their reoccurrence
we will also discuss some of the
lifestyle modifications you can do to
prevent such
infections if you want to jump straight
to the treatment part
you can do so by scrolling through the
timeline of the video below
and in the coming videos we will also be
discussing about the infections caused
by candida
and malassezia so make sure to subscribe
and press the bell icon so you don't
miss out on those videos
now let's understand how these fungi
damage our skin and cause infection
the spores from these fungi penetrate
the skin through scratching
or small cuts on the skin these pores
get embedded in the skin
and there can be various factors that
promote the growth of these fungus pores
in our skin
the alkaline ph wet and warm skin
conditions
poor hygiene contact with pets all are
favorable for the growth of these fungi
when i use the term superficial fungal
infections
it means that the infection is present
only in the top most layers of the skin
as many of you may know our skin
contains four to five layers depending
upon the region of the body
these dermatophytes only affect the
topmost layer of the skin known as
stratum corneum
this layer usually consists of dead
cells in which keratin is present
these fungi break down the keratin
present in your stratum corneum
by producing an enzyme known as
keratinase
and they use that as their food this
causes
inflammation in the skin which occurs
due to an allergic reaction in the skin
against these fungal products our
defense cells start releasing chemicals
that cause inflammation which is the
redness and itching in the infected area
these fungi can not only affect the
keratinized layers of the skin
but also the keratinized layers of our
hair and nails
these layers also contain keratin which
is used by these fungi and this leads to
an infection of the hair and nails
now let's look at the risk factors and
causes which makes a person susceptible
to tinea infections
excessive sweating in areas like groins
underarms can be an important risk
factor
environmental conditions like hot and
humid temperatures provide
more favorable conditions for these
organisms to grow
if you are keeping your body parts wet
for longer durations
the chances of getting these superficial
fungal infection increases
unexposed body parts like feet scalp
skin areas between the toes and fingers
are more susceptible as you keep them
covered
with shoes and clothes they are left
warm and wet which causes these areas to
become a suitable ground
for the breeding of these fungal
infections
improper hygienic conditions of your
household like infected clothes
blankets bed linens or contaminated
places like doorknobs
can also act as a source of infection
now all people are not equally
susceptible
it depends upon the immunity of the
individual and the ph of the skin
alkaline ph favors the growth of the
fungus
people who are low in a certain type of
proteins known as defensins
which is a type of immunity providing
protein are more susceptible to these
infections
and persons already suffering from some
underlying disease like diabetes
have higher rate of fungal infections as
compared to normal healthy individuals
these infections also occur more in
people with an immunocompromised state
it simply means that a person's immune
system cannot fight from infections
such individuals mostly are aids
patients or people who had undergone
some organ transplant surgeries
these organisms frequently attack such
type of individuals
people who take steroidal medications
for some other underlying conditions
like asthma are also frequently seen to
have these infections
younger and older people are affected
more as compared to healthy young adults
now let's talk about the different types
of teenia infections
tinea can be of various types depending
upon the location
of the infection on the body most common
infections include tinier pedis
which is a fungal infection of feet we
have teenia capitis
which is a fungal infection of the scalp
tinea angium
which is fungal infection of nails we
also have teniacrurus which is very
common and it is a fungal infection
occurring in folds of our skin like our
axillae
groin and between the hips and similarly
we have teenia corporis which is a
fungal infection involving parts of the
body
not covered with hair tinia barbae is a
fungal infection of the beard
and we have teenia amintatia which is a
thick sticky fungal infection of scalp
following infection or trauma
now let's look at some of these tinier
infections which are very common
in more detail and the first one we are
going to talk about
is tinea pedis pdfs in latin stands for
foot
and it is the most common dermatophyte
fungal infection
this fungal infection usually begins
between the toes
it is commonly known as athlete's foot
because athletes like runners and
football players are frequently affected
by these infections
it is commonly seen in people with
excessive sweating in their feet
while confined within tight fitting
shoes it spreads very easily from one
person to another
that's why we must avoid each other's
towels
socks and other clothes
it is often self diagnosed as you can
see the symptoms by yourself
you can see those areas become red and
very itchy
it almost feels satisfying when you keep
scratching those areas between your toes
the skin between your toes seems moist
all the time
and this can also lead to development of
a foul smell from your feet
another common example of teenage
infection is tinea capitis
and it is a major issue as it sometimes
causes permanent baldness
that's why it's very important to
understand it capitis stands for scalp
so it is a fungal infection affecting
the scalp area and develops
inside the hair follicles and skin of
the scalp
if you are using each other's combs you
can get these infections very easily
you can also acquire these infections
frequently from your pets
its symptoms are very straightforward
and the diagnosis is also based on the
examination of the scalp
you can experience a very itchy and
sometimes a painful scalp
the hair becomes brittle they lose their
shine and break very easily upon
minimal plucking you can also experience
low grade fever
more severe forms are presented with pus
coming out
and permanent bald spots and scarring
which is stressful
both mentally and aesthetically
the diagnosis is made by examining those
spots
on a scalp under uv woods lamp
your doctor can also take samples of
your hair to examine them under the
microscope
and some of the samples from the skin of
scalp to confirm the diagnosis
now let's look at another superficial
fungal infection known as tiniacroris
which is very very common the word kura
signifies legs
but the infection that we are going to
talk about does not occur on the legs
but in between the legs that is the
groin area
it affects the skin of the genitals
inner thighs
and sometimes buttocks this condition is
known as jock itch
this condition is common in people who
wear tight clothing
tight clothing traps moisture and favors
the growth of this fungus
symptoms of tinea crew race include
severe itching in the groin area
the area becomes red and often a
ring-shaped rash develops in the area
we will look at other types of teenia
like tinia angum and tina barbe in
separate videos
so make sure to subscribe to mad
simplified and hit the bell icon
so you don't miss out on those videos
now we will look at the treatment part
of these
tenure infections especially the tinia
pedis tina cruris antinea corporis
because fungi thrive in moist warm
environments
patients should be encouraged to wear
loose fitting garments made of cotton or
synthetic materials
designed to wick moisture away from the
surface
socks should also have similar
properties
areas likely to become infected should
be dried completely
covering with clothes patients should be
advised to
avoid walking barefoot and sharing
garments
if we look at the treatment itself it
can be divided into topical antifungals
which are applied over the skin and oral
medication
topical medication includes soaps body
washes
lotions creams and gels we will look at
them
one by one and see which one is best for
you
topical antifungals are the first line
of treatment for many patients of tener
corporis
tiniacroris as well as tineapedius
the most effective topical antifungals
include drugs like azoles
which include clottamazole ketoconazole
oxyconazole and certaconazole we also
have allylamines
like terminofin and butanophane and we
have newer antifungals like
cyclopiroxolamine
and selenium sulphide which are also
very effective
now you can start the treatment with a
soap or body wash
containing clotter muscle one percent or
ketoconazole two percent
and use that to wash your body every day
you can also use cyclopiroxolamine or
selenium sulphide washes especially if
you are having fungal infections of the
scalp or hair
when you apply the soap or the body wash
make sure to leave it on for a few
minutes before you wash it off
so as to have the maximum anti-fungal
effect
next we move on to the antifungal creams
gels
or lotions you should use again
similar antifungal drugs are present in
these creams and lotions
like ketoconazole two percent
chlortremazole one percent
laliconazole one percent eberconazole or
certaconazole
selenium sulphide two point five percent
lotion and cyclopirox one percent cream
are also very effective
you can apply these creams and lotions
twice daily
once in the morning and once before
sleeping
i have provided the links to some of the
best anti-fungal soaps
body washes creams and lotions in the
description box
down below so make sure to check them
out
as per my experience as a dermatologist
i have found lalikunazole one percent
cream
selenium sulfide and cycloperoxolamine
creams to be quite effective in the
treatment of tinea cruris
and tinea corporis
the treatment with these topical drugs
should be continued for a minimum
of four weeks if you have a mild
infection
and if you have a severe infection
involving larger areas of skin
or fungal infection that reoccurs after
you stop the treatment
you should continue the topical
treatment for at least 6
to 8 weeks
now let's talk about the oral antifungal
drugs that we use for the treatment of
denia
oral antifungal drugs are indicated in
case of extensive
involvement of the skin and in patients
who fail to respond to the topical
therapy such as creams and lotions now
there are three main fda approved
anti-fungal drugs
the benefit itraconazole and fluconazole
these drugs act by inhibiting certain
enzymes
that are very important for the fungi to
synthesize their cell wall
without a proper cell wall these fungi
cannot grow
and they soon die out of these three
fluconazole is mainly indicated for the
treatment of vaginal candidiasis
oropharyngeal candidiasis and esophageal
candidiasis
while etraconazole and turbinafine are
mainly used for the treatment of teenia
and we will focus on them etraconazole
is available in 100 milligram
200 milligram and 400 milligram dosages
for teenia crores usually 100 milligram
dose
twice a day or 200 milligram dose once a
day
for two weeks is the minimum you should
take this drug
terminofeen has been used for tinea
corporis antina crores
at 250 milligram tablet daily
for two to four weeks these drugs are
usually not available over the counter
so you need a prescription from a
dermatologist or else
you can also get a prescription from
many pharmacy websites
which have online consultations with a
dermatologist
while undergoing this treatment make
sure you take proper care of your
hygiene and wash your clothes
regularly with hot water also make sure
to iron your undergarments before
each use as many of the times the fungal
spores can get deposited in our inner
wear clothes
and this can cause frequent relapses and
treatment failures
so that was all about teenia crores
antinea corporis
in the coming videos we will discuss
more about tinea pedis
linear capitis and onychomycosis which
is the fungal infection of the nails
and many other topics related to fungal
infections
as these are such a common problem also
i am going to make some videos regarding
home remedies and natural methods to
treat tinea infections
so make sure to subscribe and hit the
bell icon so you don't miss out on those
videos
thank you so much for watching this
video if you found this video helpful
make sure to like the video and also
share with someone
who you think might find it useful bye
bye and see you
in the next video